speaking of radical you know
one of the few voices of reason recently
in politics is kanye west
i know that sounds crazy i never
expected that to happen
kanye west who's always been a little
kooky in his career
is saying things in politics now that
are extraordinarily wise he's against
abortion
he's pro-god
he supports america so we wore the make
america great again hat
he realizes that politics is about more
than just technocratic policies
it's about a view of the human person in
the world
he's been saying a lot of great things
and so
everyone's calling him crazy everybody's
calling him crazy
now kanye has certain issues
psychological issues
but listen to the note this is from
kanye's wife kim kardashian kim
kardashian west
who posted this to social media just
yesterday
as many of you know kanye has bipolar
disorder anyone who has this or has a
loved one in their life who does this
knows how incredibly complicated and
painful it is to understand then she
goes on and says all sorts of nice
things about kanye
we as a society talk about giving grace
to the issue of mental health as a whole
however we should also give it to the
individuals who are living with it
in times when they need it the most sure
totally agree with that
that's fine i'm not questioning kim
kardashian
west's a care for her husband
and i'm not questioning that kanye has
had very public psychological issues in
the past
however in the past when kanye has done
or said
actually crazy things
people are pretty quiet about it yeah
you know they'll laugh about it or maybe
they'll criticize him
they won't concern troll him but when
kanye west says basic things like babies
or babies and we shouldn't kill them
or god exists and we should we should do
good things and not do bad things
or when he says i like america i love
america
pretty basic things then
everyone goes out and says he's insane
you got to lock him up you got to
shut him up that is the sign not of
an insane kanye whether whether or not
kanye is sane or insane or how sane he
is or how insane he is
that is a that's the baseline what's
changed here
is he's saying things that are true that
is the sign
of an insane culture and i i think we
should
of course encourage kanye to live a
wonderful good life
and take care of himself and his family
and we should also encourage him to
continue saying the basic true things
that not that long ago everyone would
have agreed on but in this
lunatic culture people seem to think is
crazy
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure
to check out the full episode linked in
the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you